[Music]
you might have thought that no one who
has ever stepped on a lego brick could
possibly doubt
the reality of physical objects yet from
heraclitus to berkeley many philosophers
have claimed to have disproven that uh
mind independent things exist could the
world truly be made up of fields and
processes rather than physical stuff are
the everyday objects that surround as an
illusion or is science in a
philosophical fantasy which needs escape
or are these all completely the wrong
questions in the first place that's what
we will find out from our panel peter
atkins james ladyman joanna cavena i
won't give them detailed introductions
because we're short of time and you can
find out more about them in the program
we want to know what they think we're
going to start with three-minute opening
positions which they'll set out their
broad stalls with a very broad question
are everyday objects around us illusory
peter
well i'd hoped you'd go for a longer
introduction to give me time to think
but i intend to
take an extreme view
which i will
uh attempt to defend against all
opposition throughout this debate if
there is any opposition of course it
might be accepted immediately um
but and
it's up to you to judge whether i i'm
actually pretending to adopt this or
whether i really believe it
or whether i'm really pretending to
pretend
etc
um i'm going to take the view that
ultimate reality is mathematics
uh that everything that there is is
somehow or other and i
i'll have to explore what i mean by
somehow or other uh simply
a kind of realization of mathematics
and i think it the clue to
why i think that
is that mathematics is such an important
component of our description of physical
reality it's it's extraordinary that
mathematics proves to be the language
turns out to be the language of
of discovery
and
uh and comprehension if you like in the
in the physical sciences why does
mathematics
suit
so well
the the physical reality that we
seem to encounter
and there are all sorts of analogies
between um the physical reality and
mathematics i mean think of the integers
once you've got the integers as chronica
said um that the rest is doing thing
mathematics is doing things for the
integers that they weren't intended to
in the first place and out of that
springs the whole of the
construct of mathematics and all its
elaborate forms
but where do the integers come from they
come from the empty set and sets that
contain the empty set and so on you can
build up an idea of the integers from
absolutely nothing and this world of
course sprang from absolutely nothing so
there are deep analogies i think between
the emergence of this elaborate world
and the emergence of an elaborate
mathematical structure
but then somehow or other and maybe this
will unfold in the course of our
discussion
and we've got to find out what it means
for tangible objects
to be manifestations
of mathematical
entities
thank you as a lot to unpick there i
hope we get to unpick at least some of
it i'm james
right so i want to begin by saying that
there are some things that we can see
which aren't real and some things that
are real that we can't see i think both
those statements are pretty obvious but
just give you the
example
and this will make the distinction
between an illusion and something
subjective or private to imaginary to me
take a rainbow
why isn't a rainbow real
well for a very long time people have
thought to be real it's not enough that
everyone agrees that they can see
something there the point about a
rainbow is that you can only perceive it
through vision
so it's a public illusion
everybody sees it
but you can only see it through only
encounter it through vision it's not
possible to bump into a rainbow or hear
a rainbow
encounter a rainbow in any other way
than through this one sense and so it's
right to distinguish between a rainbow
and the table is the table although i
might think okay i get limited
information about it by seeing it but i
can also bump into it and i can also
weigh it and other other people
bump into it and encounter it as well
so with that distinction in mind the
distinction between an illusion and
what's what's private and also just to
establish that there are things that we
can see that aren't real like rainbows
we also need to admit that there are
things that are real that we can't see
such as for example electromagnetic
radiation outside the visual spec visual
spectrum
visible spectrum we all know that
radiation is there because we get our
mobile phone signals right we all know
that diseases that we can't see can kill
us we know that radiation that we can't
see can kill us so there are definitely
things that
exist that common sense doesn't tell us
anything about which we wouldn't know
existed if we hadn't done further
investigation
and so in general we shouldn't think
that common sense is a particularly good
guide to what there is
now science tells us about loads of
things that exist
and um
i don't want to go on for too long at
this point i have some more to say later
but i would say that
really we don't need to put the issue in
terms of everyday things versus
subatomic particles or fields or
whatever we can put the issue in terms
of scientific kinds that aren't
fundamental
and particles or fields or whatever so
let's just think about peter's subject
matter in chemistry molecules those
things are not fundamental in science
they're higher level entities there are
lots of things like that that science
studies
big entities that are nonetheless
real
physical you might say but not the
ultimate fundamental stuff is if there
is any such thing so if we're going to
deny the existence of everyday things
just because they're not fundamental
then we need to like deny the existence
of lots of scientific
kinds as well which i don't think is a
sensible thing to do because
these are part of what we've learned
to take account of in order to
understand the world in the same way
that we have to take account of of
tables so
uh short answer is yes there are lots of
physical things
that we only know about through science
and there are some things that we
encounter in common sense that aren't
real lots of things that are it's a very
uh sort of common sensical position but
i think important to note that it's
common sense to think that
in the light of the development advanced
science that tells us that there's lots
of stuff like microwaves that we
otherwise wouldn't know about and so it
wouldn't have been common sense to think
what i think
you know in previous ages just is now
okay thank you joanna thank you very
much um
so this is a kind of really interesting
question which has this huge history
behind it as we've been hearing and
there's if you think of philosophy as a
kind of boxing match why not um in the
in the sort of red corner there are the
physicalists the materialists who you
know adopt the view that the physical
world is what we can be sure of the
stuff that we can kind of be sure of
look at make sense of
and you have johnson in refutation of
barclay you know i've kicked the stone
my foot hurts that kind of refutation
and then in the sort of blue corner you
have the idealist tradition the
anti-materialist tradition this idea
that really you can be sure any of your
minds that's the thing you're sure of
and everything else is a bit dodgy
potentially and this goes back to the
ancient eastern traditions the
upanishads where creation begins with i
am that's the first kind of moment in
creation and then the world
and also barclay's kind of idea which we
now see as subjective idealism this idea
that
for him it was a kind of it was a
synthesized reality because of god you
know because of the mind of god
perceiving everything so it was all okay
you can then kind of start playing with
that if your bookheads for example um
the great sort of
writer of the 20th century who had this
idea if you don't have god anymore in
that tradition what happens and he had a
short story called telon ukbar turtius
orbis where he imagines if subjective
reality is the only thing then the
danger is that this tent would disappear
if someone wasn't looking at it and it
would be a real problem and so entire
civilizations have been saved by a flock
of birds flying past just at the right
moment that kind of idea so you know you
can have a lot of fun with the
extremities of these theories
and physicalism gets into terrible
trouble with the self this problem
because you can't find a physical thing
called the self
it doesn't exist and you get the sort of
arch physicalist view that the self is
an illusion which leads to that
wonderfully mad sentence i myself
believe there is no self which you know
causes all sorts of fascinating problems
of how a non-existent self can refute
its own reality so i think you know it's
a really fascinating question at the
risk of sounding like i want to stop the
boxing match which is you know i i don't
at all um asking the pugilists to be
friends i think there's also one further
point
that i'd like to make about this
irrespective of whether we're going to
arrive at a sense of the truth of
everything now at this moment which i
fear we may not
there is this possibly
a fact that we might all accept which is
that we're all having a subjective
experience we're all here as a unique
human seeing the world and so
our experience is always mediated
through the self so you never escape
that even in the most beautiful science
there's always a perceiver
doing the perceiving there's always
someone there and that's kind of the
sort of interim position i'd like to
take thank you
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas